el comandante ya no tiene a su cargo una
las posiciones de las fuerzas ucranianas
al este de la ciudad de severodonezk
el último ataque fue hace unas horas
atacaron la posición vecina los atacaron
con bombas racimo fósforo con todo lo
que quisieron
las tropas rusas están en el bosque a
menos de un kilómetro
mientras
es así
la batalla por severodonezk y la
provincia a los hanks es la más intensa
que se libra actualmente en ucrania esta
es una de las tres poblaciones al oeste
de cebrones que todavía permanecen en
control de los ucranianos para ellos son
fundamentales porque de llegar las a
perder la ciudad quedaría prácticamente
encerrada las tropas rusas atacan sin
cesar estas poblaciones cientos de
integrantes del ejército de moscú que
han sido expulsados en las últimas
semanas de otras regiones de ucrania
pelean en este frente ahora por nuestros
de subir ahora todas las fuerzas rusas
se están trasladando a este territorio
es muy difícil es muy complicado
utilizan tanques pero especialmente la
artillería como estrategia para doblegar
a la defensa ucraniana como resultado
van dejando poblaciones destruidas y
muchas veces arrasadas
el comandante aldea y tiene a su cargo
la defensa de otra posición hay un gran
riesgo al estar en este pueblo han
atacado en frente de la casa atacaron la
casa de los vecinos están tratando de
destruir todo por completo ellos ven un
asentamiento y su objetivo es destruirlo
aquí todos tienen que permanecer bajo
techo los drones rusos sobrevuelan
haciendo trazados sobre el terreno
este es el cuarto de operaciones su
estrategia disuadir al enemigo y no dará
la oportunidad de atacar
para esto se apoyan en las nuevas armas
enviadas por países occidentales como
esta lanzadera
[Música]
en los bosques donde los tanques y el
equipo pesado del enemigo no puede pasar
tenemos menos pero en otros terrenos
abiertos con mayor amenaza hay más y
todos los hombres saben ahora cómo
usarlos y
[Música]
reconocen que la llegada de este
armamento ha elevado la moral aún así
saben que esta es una de las batallas
más difíciles
rusia tiene superioridad aérea y ahora
enfoca toda su fuerza en tomar el
control de severodonezk